philippe legorjus bonsoir vous écoutiez
attentivement ce soir tous nos
reportages que pensez vous de ce climat
de violence je vous rappelle que vous
êtes
l'ancien commandant du gign écoutez ce
climat de violence me rappelle et
malheureusement des actes de violence
que j'ai eu à connaître lorsque j'étais
patron du gign actes de violence plus
redoutable encore peut-être puisque
c'étaient des actes qui généralement
porté la mort de certaines personnes
mais ce que je vois aujourd'hui c'est
aussi une violence contre l'esprit et
lorsque l'on en est à ce stade on n'est
pas loin de ce qu'on a pu connaître une
aussi alors philippe legorjus on vous a
invité pour un livre que vous venez
d'écrire la morale et l'action publié
par les éditions fitch ont gelé dit tout
à l'heure vous étiez le commandant du
gign à 34 ans et vous avez été l'un des
acteurs du drame d'ouvea lors votre
livre se lit comme un roman mais c'est
pas un roman c'est un vrai si la prise
d'otages oui c'est je crois pas que ce
soit uniquement un récit prise d'otage
je crois que j'ai voulu au delà des
faits essayer de voir comment on pouvait
à partir de règles de règles morales que
l'on peut s'imposer personnellement ou
que l'on respecte dans la vie en société
on pouvait confronter ces règles à des
phénomènes de violence comme ceux dont
on vient de parler et à trouver des
moyens à la fois techniques et moraux de
résoudre ces problèmes de violence alors
bien sûr la sphère d'ouvéa philippe
legorjus vous avez été vous étiez bien
sûr le commandant du gign mais vous avez
aussi joué un rôle très politique
pendant ces événements à mon niveau je
ne considère pas que c'est un rôle
politique
lorsque vous avez à traiter une affaire
de prise d'otages vous essayez de la
traiter dans sa globalité afin d'obtenir
le meilleur résultat possible par
effectivement vous prenez en compte les
paramètres politiques
et si vous vous apercevez un moment ou
un autre du traitement de la crise qu'il
faut aussi jouer d'une façon ou d'une
autre sur le politique bien vous le
faites je crois qu'il faut pas avoir de
regrets par rapport à ça c'est parce que
je considère de c'est pas une attitude
marginal désobéissante par rapport à des
règles établies
c'est la volonté de prendre tous les
moyens pour arjen solution de libération
d'otages
mais vous étiez très perturbé par la
coïncidence entre ce drame d'ouvea
l'élection présidentielle mais
l'élection présidentielle était
j'allais dire presque la cause de cette
prise d'otages c'est parce qu'il ya des
élections présidentielles très
certainement que les mélanésiens ont
décidé d'attaquer la brigade de fayaoué
est d'associer des quatre gendarmes
aussi toi mais c'est tout de même vous
qui avait tenu l'elysée au courant j'ai
tenu au courant et nous dit dans livres
tout à fait j'ai tenu au courant un
homme à l'elysée c'est ce que je dis
dans le livre cet homme s'appelle
christian prouteau
il est le fondateur du gign et
contrairement à ce qu'on a pensé
j'ai toujours cru que le gouvernement de
l'époque informées normalement par les
voies normales l'elysée ce que je
voulais c'est que le président à travers
christian couteau et est vraiment une
appréciation j'ai à dire presque
psychologique et intimiste de la façon
dont vous pouvez résoudre le problème
vous parlez souvent de violences dans
votre livre dans votre vie mais ce n'est
pas le sentiment que la politique est
quelque fois encore plus violentes qu'on
imagine
et quel jeu cher quelquefois non j'ai
pas vraiment cette impression moss est
aujourd'hui à travers l'action qui était
la mienne comme chef du gign
j'ai établi une réflexion et cette
réflexion ce qu'il faut aider au
contraire le politiques à résoudre
techniquement et en dehors de toute
contingence je sais pas si le mot est
bien choisi essayer de bien résoudre de
bien visionnez la
la finalité de respect de la vie et de
la mort par rapport aux acteurs des
unités d'intervention comme celle que je
demande c'est curieux vous semblez à la
fois lucide et un petit peu quand est ce
que vraiment la morale à sa place dans
l'action et est ce que vraiment la
morale à sa place dans l'action
politique
je crois que la morale à sa place dans
la vie tout court quelle que soit la
forme cette vie merci philippe legorjus